I was telling the audience before the
show that I'm such a big fan of yours
and and there's so many of your movies
where I can recite lines and I realized
I actually went in and was talking to
you about Barton Fink and how your
specific lunch from Barton Fink and how
I know them and I know the timing of
them and I thought you must get this all
the time you probably have people coming
up to you all the time and they've
memorized lines of yours from movies one
well yeah and when people know the lines
you know most of them I've I've I've
heard like I remember right but I
remember one time a guy was in Vegas and
the guy came up to me with his
girlfriend and he said my character's
name from The Big Lebowski like to his
last name which I never even learned his
last name it only gets I think John
Goodman mentions it in the eulogy right
it gives for me like in the film right
he do you have to be a super fan yeah I
mean you'd have to because your your
whole name has never said no in the
whole movie except I think at one point
in the movie and if you have to really
be listening for it
so this fan came up and said he said my
last name in it and and started talking
about the character and I didn't know
what he was talking about and he got so
embarrassed in front of his girlfriend
and he then he was looking at me like I
was like really pissed off at me like
yeah why are you doing this to me right
you know what I'm talking about
sorry Theodore Donald care about shows
is there you know yeah yeah like I
didn't know yeah I was just Donny this
is why I wasn't allowed to hang out it
was you for so many years no it's true I
have people that that there because I
worked for this on The Simpsons years
and years ago there are people that know
everything about The Simpsons and
they'll come up and they'll start saying
stuff to me and I haven't I left to do
this show 27 years ago right and so
they'll be like yeah because that and
I'll be like wait who's the bus driver I
think it mad like how could you not know
it's Otto and I'm like if you say so and
then I say who's the boy and they're
like it's Bart